welcome welcome everybody
to episode one of
the october fest spook season hashtag
spook season on tick tock
i feel spooky my ass is fat james
charles this week
i don't think i think you've never
looked better to be honest like you
looked so good like i didn't want to be
like over the top when i came in because
like i have my boyfriend here but i was
like whoa
do you think that i'm attractive like
yeah this is like no i'm not kidding
this is like my ideal man like i like a
mask but it was like femininity to it
you look a little more manny mua because
he's a little thick boy too and i think
you look like him more
i think i look like a monster just
because if i shave my face so i'm not
used to seeing myself without a beard
oh the beard uh hides my face and so i'm
insecure without it but then with the
makeup and everything and i think i'm
gained weight so i just look like a big
fat monster i disagree with glamorous
three
no you're like you're like the
traditional fat girl that has a pretty
face like oh my god your face is so
pretty like that is your face oh that's
so nice of you
yeah that girl with the pretty face
that's what people say to me like you'd
be so pretty if you lost 30 pounds like
howard stern said it about me he said i
looked like pamela anderson if if i lost
40 pounds like she looked just like
family anderson i was like oh okay thank
you
when i was on america's got talent so is
that is that a compliment i mean it's
like a little insulting but like
i mean it's better than being a fat girl
with an ugly face right you know
yeah right you look great you look your
face is your money maker like honestly i
think your face is your best feature
and i think you should shave more um
i like to hide my face well who are you
who are you dressed as
okay can i just say i was just prefacing
that i was gonna start the halloween
episodes because i was gonna come in
costume in october anyways
and i didn't really put much thought
into it i just go with like the tick
tock theme so i was like oh i'm gonna be
like elwood's legally blonde it's like
cute and funny but you're like
all your costumes are overshadowing me
and i already had my all planned so i'm
like oh [ __ ] i didn't know which is
funny because you were bitching out at
me
about not wanting to do it and now i'm
i'm all in i
know and then you kind of showed up i'm
underwhelmed to be honest
no because you know this is like what
how you dress every day you're just like
no i have bunny ears on every no every
day in october i dress up in a costume i
have costumes planned for every single
day
every day yeah i have every single day
planned out well you should bring your
best ones
but i didn't think you were gonna dress
up so i'm like you know what i'm gonna
just bring like more casual ones but i
just wanted to preface i'm coming in
costumes so you're like why are you
dressed like a bunny today so i was like
prefacing that all of a sudden you and
ella just went like full force i'm like
oh my god we're gonna get his hair and
makeup done i was like wait what the
like i would have come to someone i kind
of was like jeffrey stars i'm like i
could have you know
you shut up well i didn't no i can't
yeah three more
chances because you have to plan you
guys are not planners i'm a planner i
have to plan my costume my makeup my
hair
we talked ahead of time and and
coordinated no i saved your guys's ass
because okay whatever i look great we
don't need to argue about the fact that
i look great i know it's my makeup
artist
i gave you guys my second i gave you my
second choice makeup artist and you guys
didn't book far enough in advance so i
was like
[ __ ] and as i was like fine use my first
choice i guess wait you didn't want to
give me your
your star player because you didn't want
me to overshadow no no because then we
couldn't start on time like we're
starting three hours late and i have
stuff to do so i gave you my second
one because you guys don't plan very
well he didn't get back to you in time
but i knew my girl's on top of [ __ ] so i
was like all right yours is her number
so um i this is the first time i've
gotten makeup though i do have
dude you do this like every day um just
like special days
not every day i do especially days like
how often do you do this she says she's
at your house twice a week twice a week
i was just gonna say twice a week
a lot yeah because i do only think it
takes like two hours
oh my gosh three hours sometimes because
of my hair your hair was like not your
face needs more work than mine
i don't think so i think we look
identical actually which was so scary i
was like i feel like we're gonna look
the same because i do
feel like i just look like a big fat
james charles though like
they nailed it and unfortunately i had a
hair style i don't know if you guys can
tell but i've got a
thick fresh fade bro with the vanilla
ice and everything here
it looks good it looks good my only
regret is that i cut my hair already
because he could have done it like the
perfect james charles like the poof yeah
i heard he wanted to like dye it and add
hair to it and stuff you guys don't know
you should just like fall out and done
it i wanted to do it but i don't have
any hair no but he could have like added
hair to it
whatever anyways you look great and you
do look like james charles you should do
like i don't know maybe
i feel like you love james charles loki
like i feel like you're kind of like
fond of him the way you were with me
remember you kind of like hated me but
then you're kind of like oh i kind of
like fond of this person
no i don't think so i think he's just a
douche to be honest
after interacting with him i don't feel
like you're i feel like you're
i feel that you're crazy but i don't
think you're a douche no yeah i get you
yeah i think he
thinks he's a douche i don't know if you
i don't know him well enough to say is a
bad heart but like he's pretty evil that
whole beauty community really
like tattoos he's evil yeah what do you
know about him you know i've never met
him just everybody i know
has like horrific experiences with him
like horrific
and i'm not trying to be that person be
like oh i know stuff like i don't really
know because i don't know but just like
things i've heard i mean i heard he's
like actually like a horrible person
just like
yeah but i don't know i mean well so so
anyway the reason
we're doing a couple of things today
we're going to
um by the way i have a lie detector
because james charles
he took a lie detector test and they
asked if he ripped off teddy fresh
he said no and the guy was like that's
true
so so he's g so he's absolved and i
thought i would hook myself up to a lie
detector like for example let's say
um why don't you go ahead and ask maybe
if uh james charles ripped off too
fresh did james charles rip off teddy
fresh yes
that is true see ah so it's a conflict
of the lie detector
oh you're saying it like depends on the
person asking the question yeah but you
know the guy who well let me show you
this video
let me show you this teddy fresh here oh
this guy he does everyone's
that was true that's true they're like
see
oh see but you know this guy wait is he
being serious or is he like trolling
like is james charles trolling
no he's being serious he's like i am
absolved but he literally said oh yeah
it is it is probably the same thing
sorry like he said it to you so he
already
like he already admitted yeah but he
steals a lot of things like you know
like the makeup look i thought you were
doing the white paint look because he
stole it so i was like oh he's doing
like stolen look so
yeah someone like you but he has a
history of stealing things so i'm like
so confused as why people don't like
call him out on it i was like wait but
he's
i guess because he has money but you
know what people like that always like
come down like he's gonna be like a toby
turner or something like where the
people just don't care
or shay carl like one of those people
where he's like flirting with like well
i guess he's already flirted with people
and got in trouble but
he'll like be brought down somehow
because they're like not good people do
you think
do you think do you want to ask me a yes
or no question
okay um do you think i'm hot
no that's true
um by the way this [ __ ] is scientific
bro
there is nothing wrong with this lie
detector any more questions because it's
so it's like ask me anything go ahead
ask me anything
how dare you this this
this is top of the line [ __ ] go ahead
ask me one more question
anything okay um
do you oh i don't know what to ask do
you want to have sex with me
wow really is just all about how much
you really your mind is one place
that's all i ask for uh no that is uh
true oh you could have this such yeah
that's such a lie like we know that's a
lie
like whatever no i definitely don't want
to [ __ ] you you definitely
do because you want to like i just feel
like you either want to like be me or be
in me you know like one day
i don't want to be either of those
things one or the other do you think
that everybody wants to be
you or be yeah for sure it's one or the
other always
so moses obviously wants to be in you
yeah for sure always you cannot imagine
a world where people don't want to be
you or be in
it's not there's not a world that exists
like that like i swear on my life like
everybody wants to like
be me or be in me always and you don't
trust me when i say i have no desire to
[ __ ] you or
yeah i know you're lying
you look so pretty right now it's insane
so here you want to do this uh are you
smarter than a fifth grader
yeah for sure but can i just say one
more thing about the live detector guy
i've been hooked up to him like check
out
like me on his videos like i've been
hooked up to him and he literally will
say like oh
i can give you whatever answer you want
yeah dude i
knew that guy was such a scammer
obviously he's in like everybody
straight up just says you can say
whatever you want yeah no he says oh
tell me what you want me to say
what yeah oh for sure when i got hooked
up to it he literally was like oh
like they're like no no say yes to that
say no to that like i'm like okay
he's not like real that is disgusting
though
i know this because he's been in shane's
videos he's one of jason's videos he's
been in david's videos he's like in
everyone's like lie detector i think
people just assume that
he's trustworthy or something but the
thing is like lie detectors
are a pseudoscience they're not even
allowed in you know
court yeah it's a total suicide it just
it just measures your pulse and stuff
if you squeeze your butthole you send
all the measurements wow because it
increases your blood pressure oh yeah
yeah
you just squeezed your butthole you
looked up on that too
no i did it i had to do a lie detector
test for a job i applied for in israel
for an interview and it was so it was
just so demeaning no it wasn't like i
love israeli flex
trust me it's not a flex it was like 30
000 a year it was a [ __ ]
but they go have you ever used drugs oh
i was like [ __ ] you next question
and what happened well i was like you
get the job no i didn't because
apparently i failed on the drug question
wait what oh because you said [ __ ] you
you have to say yes or no no i said no
oh and they said oh untruthful i was
like dude go [ __ ] hot what is this
the fbi is a dumbass job so maybe it was
right you did do
you have done drugs you told me yeah no
i know i was alive yeah
oh well then that makes sense why they
didn't hide no but it's like it's just
such
[ __ ] that um yeah i agree i don't
think it's not like the cia i was like
writing articles for some
[ __ ] israel you don't even speak
hebrew
how to get a job over there really who
knew
i did wait so now that you feel fat are
you like not gonna have sex like all
week
no that won't get in my way i stopped
having sex with my field father i
haven't had sex in three days because i
feel so fat
really i'm like don't touch me it's just
lately why have i been so fat lately
well you told me on the way here you
stopped at mcdonald's
i couldn't stop eating yesterday i just
kept shoving my face
you know what it was i got depressed
about something i can't remember i got
to press and then once that depression
kicks in i'm just like
[ __ ] it like everything yeah i want to
do that yeah
do you do it i have pizza this weekend
you do
you know so you guys did a photo shoot
i'm kind of kind of over this whole
topic of like about you guys
yeah like we know we love jews oh but
speaking of jew real quick and i promise
no but you guys took a only fans photo
can i bring up something about a jew
real quick that i love um rick morana's
like why are
more people not talking about i used to
love miranda so much and he got hit he
got punched in the face and
oh why would that why who would want to
assault him he's like such a sweet
lovable dude
yeah pure is gold i love just a random
act of violence
i guess but did you see the video it's
literally broad daylight upper east side
this guy just like
like punches him in the face and nothing
happens he doesn't get arrested nothing
did they find him i heard they found the
guy who did it yeah but he didn't get
arrested
no he must have gotten around no i'm a
hardcore mercian if you watch my old
videos like i always talk about rick
moranis yeah everyone loves it here
here's the photos you see what we did
so we can show it she was butt ass naked
and then
ian photoshopped a dress on you so we
could show it
what oh you can't show the nudity no and
then he did another one of you as
a nun that's kind of cute though i like
it i honestly
i kind of like the photo i'm not even
gonna hate it's pretty did you see the
original the pamela anderson when i
posted it yeah okay so it was like it
was
inspired by um the colors are nice
it's got a gucci photo shoot vibe that's
what everyone was saying thank you
yeah it was cute we have another one
coming up because we're gonna put these
on some billboards
but you know his parents are gonna freak
did your parents say anything or
your family i mean i know
i know hey you're preaching in the choir
no but here's the thing i'm dressed no
his mom's on our side now she called him
saturday and i was like glad you're in a
relationship right i mean that's what
you told me i don't speak your group
just don't just don't show bro
let's do are you smarter than a fifth
grader because this would be fun
i love this wait are we not having a
podcast it's just like a fun halloween
episode or what
what are you what is that we're doing a
podcast we are but like are we not
talking about topics so we're just like
this i figured as the person who
actually does work and plans
me that we would do yeah me i'm the one
that do planning oh got it
i do planning too no you don't my
earring just broke okay let's do it
let's start
are you and the reason that i wanted to
play are you smarter than fifth grade
with you
is because you have kind of a sometimes
a pretty funny
explanation for things thank you that's
such a nice thing to say
i think it's a nice way of insulting you
i'll take it honestly i love you right
now you look so hot today
well i can't do any wrong this is crazy
how beautiful you are
that's why your baby looks so good we
were talking actually me and the makers
were talking like oh this baby's like
low-key cute
low-key what do you mean well you want
to think that right no because you're
like quirky you know what i mean you're
like a quirky looking person but without
your facial beard you look [ __ ]
gorge yeah my baby's cute
low-key but you wouldn't expect no he's
hiki but you wouldn't expect it like
loki i don't know anyways
okay whatever whatever definitely don't
want to [ __ ] you
let's go so anyway i i you always have
really funny answers to historical stuff
oh historical i'm good at this okay
great so so go ahead
and give us some categories a or who's
reading them off
dan okay so give us some categories and
trisha will choose i don't know the
answers to any of these these guys put
them together
and we will both um we will both compete
so what do we win
how about whoever wins the other person
has to sell them a thousand dollars so
if i win today i sell you a thousand
for real yeah i totally i mean you'll
definitely lose
oh my god no but will you actually sell
me a thousand dollars yeah yeah but i i
will win
i will i mean you have no chance are you
kidding me i'm way smarter than you and
i know this like people think i'm stupid
and i like that
oh wow i'm about to make a g baby are
you kidding me oh my god yeah i know i
spent a thousand on this [ __ ] hair
makeup so i'm about to recoup
oh yeah that's true it is expensive but
a write-off
because you only can use it for another
it's a write-off but you're still like
i tell everyone how boutique you got all
right i'm not really
let's go ask the questions i saw ella's
car i was like okay eva like so bougie
by the way you guys can text me whenever
moses told me that you guys like feel
bad because i think you guys take some
when i say he's like to heart like if
i'm like don't talk about that but i'm
not gonna text you past
[ __ ] six okay but you can text me you
guys like we're silent and i'm like okay
you can text me like something i do the
majority of my texting past six
i'm just busy during the day and then
i'm like hey what's going on
forget about it well ela is better at
texting so i'll just text with her i
don't care about texting let's play the
game
go ahead dan give us some categories
categories that we have available are
um we have history uh
english and literature geography or
science which which one would you like
am i picking for him are we doing why
don't we switch off you pick first and
then i'll pick and we have to both do
the same category
yeah yeah yeah we'll both answer the
question and then
he'll tell us the right answer okay can
you read the categories one more time so
sorry
sure it's history so sorry english
geography or science okay we're gonna go
with english
english it is like billy madison at the
end when like bradley whitford goes
against adam sandler and then he loses
and pulls a gun and like shoots up crap
you really think you're gonna beat me
yeah a thousand percent like that's a
that's a given
like yeah and if you lose will you admit
that
like not everybody wants to [ __ ] you no
how can you not entertain the idea that
there are dudes not attractive i've
never
okay yes not attractive but everybody
would want to [ __ ] me for sure
well why would i want to [ __ ] someone
i'm not attracted i mean it happens all
the time a lot of people tell me i'm
like
like afterwards after i stop hooking up
with someone like you're gross you're
chubby whatever i'm like alright but you
[ __ ] me so like everyone wants to [ __ ]
they all insult you afterwards oh but
like i was like that's [ __ ] up
it's really sad it's actually really
yeah that is sad twice but it's fine i
mean that's exactly i can
guarantee you dan doesn't want to [ __ ]
you
but you say this to your navy yeah you
say this to your little posse because
i don't think everyone wants to [ __ ] you
okay well
that's cute like just because like
you've been like marrying for 12 years
i feel like you low-key wish that you
could be single while you're famous and
rich
because i feel like you didn't get that
out of your system like knowing that
every girl wants to [ __ ] you because
you're famous and rich
um i mean the dating and all that is
really stressful i hate that
but don't you wish you could date now
that you're known and have money but
don't you think you miss out a little
bit
i mean yes you do it's fine it would be
fun to
date but like i'm not interested in that
i'm
very happily married but i'm saying yeah
it would be fun to see what it's like
today when you're actually have
something going for you
because when i was dating i was a
[ __ ] i had i was broke
fat no you're skinny when you eli i saw
that yeah i was skinnier
but i'm saying like yeah it would be fun
to date when you actually have something
going for you
yeah but you just made a bunch of rapid
[ __ ] well yeah
you're missing out on seeing that
everybody wants to [ __ ] you when you
have like something going on
i'm not gonna satisfy anyone sexually
it's just gonna be embarrassing yeah but
do you think adam chandler doesn't know
it's because he's rich and famous
that is true wait where did
he come from how come i've never met him
before i've never maybe he's you know
oh he's new who did he replace he didn't
replace anyone who's new okay bougie
hiring new employees expanding the team
but i know okay i love that um where's
my check do i get a check today
yeah i owe you i do i'm gonna calculate
for you today tonight
all right let's go ahead let's do the
thing all right we said english right
yeah english yes okay so uh first grade
question
um wait do we both answer this are we
good that's how you want to do this you
want to alternate questions because i
got lots i got lots of questions
no no we'll both answer it and then you
tell us the right answer and why don't
you get it
no that's fine we both get a point all
right so let's both oh you're saying
because
so what if you copy me on my camera and
you're like yeah okay you're right
you're right you go first you pick your
category okay and a b can you keep going
you keep score okay
i feel okay all right here we go you're
gonna send me a thousand bucks it's
gonna be so happening
all right first question i uh we'll
start with trisha okay what is the
plural of moose
huh moose that's correct wow look at
this
[ __ ] uh how many letters are in the
english alphabet
ethan wait i didn't choose english
no you have to do the same category i
think it's 23.
that's incorrect it's 26. 27. holy [ __ ]
it's 26 sweating 6 or 27. in the story
doesn't matter i got it wrong
move on uh what is the term for a word
that is
uh similar in meaning to another word
wait say that one more time what is the
word
oh what is the term for a word that is
similar in meaning
to another word synonym correct what
type of words
should be capitalized ethan
what word should we capitalize yeah what
type of words
oh pronouns incorrect proper nouns
so so far we're moving on to the second
grade here
okay uh yo those first graders are
[ __ ] stacked
okay second grade um trisha what type of
literature features
magical creatures such as giants gnomes
and goblins
mythology wait if she gets it wrong do i
get a stab at it
i like that yes because i just yours
right i got proper nouns i got 26.
you're right you're right all right that
was a correct answer though so good job
um
wait what mythology how is that right
mythology mythological what do you mean
how is that right shouldn't be like
fantasy
no that would have been an acceptable
answer as well but mythology is well
mythology is like
the study of like greek god that's greek
mythology that's a different
okay whatever next [ __ ] [ __ ]
collusion okay ethan what is the term
for a word that has the opposite meaning
of another word i know it it's like
antonym that's correct thank god what is
the
uh what are the what's the score one
three okay
what are the five uh interrogative
question words
there's five of them oh who what where
when why
got it uh what are comparative and
superlative
forms of the word big ethan
bro this is some [ __ ] this is first
grade i don't even know what the
second grade this is second grade say is
repeat the question what are
comparative and superlative forms of the
word
big
i don't even know what the [ __ ] those
words you said mean bro
okay well the answer is bigger and
biggest just
[ __ ] this go ahead
uh the person in a novel who tells the
story from a third person
perspective is called what trisha
the narrator that's correct
has a perfect score so far thank you abs
uh uh ethan what is the name of the book
about a friendship between a pig named
wilbur and a spider named charlotte
that's uh
charlotte webb that's right shut up
who is the author of james and the giant
peach royal doll
no no exceptions what did you say
ronaldo
ronald dahl is incorrect it's not
ronald you have mcdonald's on your mind
it's rolled
doll is that what you're saying no no
that's what i literally you said
ronald royal doll no no no i wasn't sure
what you said she's roth she's wrong i
said it the first time i think she said
okay whatever i'm going to destroy you
in other categories
move on he also wrote charlie in the
chocolate bro you literally
said ronald a doll playback played back
the clip in editing because i literally
said roll down he's like no i'm like oh
ronald
but like that doesn't sound right i knew
his world dog we'll do an instant replay
in editing
royal doll royal doll you said james in
the giant peach right go ahead
yeah and finally the main series of
events in a story is called what ethan
the main series of events
you know what i think like the climax
no so what is those were you going to
say i would have guessed
like yeah the climax for the finale
that's the plot
that that's such a that's such an
arbitrary question
the plot did you get one right wait that
yeah i did okay one the
that's so stupid that's just a dumb
[ __ ] question oh look i'm getting so
mad oh my god that's so
arbitrary [ __ ] the plot i've never seen
you get like actually alright
and i choose next go history i'm not mad
i'm just we we still have the fourth and
the fifth
okay fourth fifth grade go ahead all
right fourth grade um
trisha what what is the main character
of a story called
oh um protagonist that's right um
what uh what type of word is truthfully
ethan
um i might just say ethan's questions
are
[ __ ] i'm just alternating i'm not i'm
not i mean i did get
his question i think truthfully is like
it's not
it's like i don't know it's not an
adjective or verb i don't know [ __ ] you
dan
[ __ ] you dan yeah [ __ ] you damn it's an
adverb
verb adverb this is the one thing i'm
really bad at
in the in the book titled the lion the
witch in the wardrobe
what is the last oh
what what is the last comma called
that's a weird question
okay you have to see it to like really
understand what that question is let's
skip that no let's not skip it
okay give her a [ __ ] question okay
in the title
the lion comma the witch comma and the
wardrobe
what is the last comma called oh
see it's not that hard to explain fair
enough
conjunction no it's called an oxford
comment
duh did you know i wouldn't no
i got wrong so sorry no i didn't know
the answer
what do you call a group of crows
how was that literature
i'm not really a group of crowd
that's not common knowledge you want to
it's called a crew obviously no it's a
murder a murderer murderer
don't give hints that's not funny i
wasn't gonna i wasn't gonna pull it
there's money on the line yeah literally
don't give hands
all right last grade fifth grade here we
go this is the big time here
um trisha yes who is the creator of the
classic book characters tom sawyer and
huckleberry finn
huh sheet
wow you really don't know wow
wait i know this i do know this and
that's so annoying
oh my gosh i don't know
she gives up move on tell me it's mark
twain mark twain oh
i thought it was a fictional character i
literally go ahead all right who is uh
ethan who is the author of the 1960
novel
about social and racial inequality to
kill a mockingbird
who's the author yes
who's the author of to kill a
mockingbird
some [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
harper lee is the answer it wasn't his
real name though you know that was a pen
name
um i love i love that movie
okay nick can we do a new category
please uh we have two more questions
here we go uh
[Laughter]
trisha what is the name of the most
famous english playwright
english do you know oh oh
is it william shakespeare it sure is
good this is so
dumb go ahead oh what's what's a bunch
of crows dan this is so stupid are you
trying to cost me a thousand bucks
you're such an [ __ ] go ahead go ahead
last question last question often seen
at the end of a sentence the
three trailing dots that indicate the
omission of speech
or writing of a word or words that are
superfluous or able to be understood
from contextual clues are known as
dot dot
a [ __ ] couple dots dude [ __ ]
it's called an ellipse in a little lips
or ellipses
ellipses right i knew that all right so
that is that is
english uh what what what what's the
score a b
the score is currently two for ethan
eight for trisha
oh god oh my god like there's a blowout
yeah that doesn't even all right so
let's move on
it's your turn
the first thanksgiving was celebrated by
native americans and what other group of
people
oh native americans no well pilgrims
sorry
yeah pilgrims native americans we'll
give you that one that's so easy that's
so dumb
okay it's first person uh trisha what
country did mexico gain its independence
from in the 19th century
what country didn't mexico gain it's
independent in the 19th century um
you wish you know the united states
it's spain let's go let's go history
history next question i'm ready i'm
prepared all right uh ethan who
invented the light bulb in 1879
thomas edison that is correct this is
[ __ ] i think oh my god this is
[ __ ]
revenge of ethanol god uh
tricia um which language is most
widely spoken in south america
you wish you knew the answer spanish
that's correct okay you got your
[ __ ] all right second grade second
grade second graders didn't know [ __ ]
stupid
all right uh ethan what are the three
branches of the
united states federal government
judicial
executive legislative legislative yes
okay nerd nerd [ __ ] nerd over here i
know this one
uh which war was fought did you know
that no i knew it but i think you look
like
you look
what's a murder of crows that's such a
stupid question
go ahead go ahead did you know murder i
didn't know murder actually
you would free no that's the thing you
learn that's like a basic thing everyone
knows
really yeah why do people think about
crows so much there's like other things
to life
i mean it's in a lot of like literature
like girls are very symbolic
wow okay talk about nerd
all right ask her a question she's gonna
get it wrong all right
trisha and what war was fought between
the north and southern regions of the
united states
the civil war dude that is a dumb dumb
question
well it is for a second grader
what was the alliance between italy
japan and germany during world war ii
called so it was called the
axis powers that's correct wow okay
that's
the holocaust don't [ __ ]
i lowkey got really sad about the
holocaust this weekend moses explained
to me what actually happened and i like
started crying
you just found out about the whole i had
no idea that they like
tricked them into going into showers and
like killed millions of them that way
have you seen chandler's list no
you should watch that i feel like i got
really sad when he said that because we
were watching the producers and they had
like springtime for hitler and i was
like oh that's cute and then he was like
telling me i'm like well what a hillary
that was so bad
oh my god and then he told me i have to
beat you
i have to beat you i can't lose you it
made me cry i'm sorry i'm
empathetic like i'm not like making a
joke like i was like no i just think i
just thought i just think you're
i can't lose everything's tied up in
this
just go ahead you didn't you just
literally asked me what did hitler do
that was so bad i didn't know really but
it's good to know and be educated so
all right well uh on the topic of world
war ii trisha the final second great
question what city
was the first to be attacked by an
atomic bomb
good luck dummy
in the u.s yeah in the u.s
why are you not given why are you giving
her hits yeah anyway oh oh oh we
was in the us it was in the us
are you being stupid okay everyone there
was a bomb dropped in the u.s a nuclear
bomb was dropped on the united states
during world war ii yeah this is like
v-day or something okay
i want to say this was in maui
right yeah pearl harbor yeah they nuked
pearl harbor
no i'm sorry correct answer is hiroshima
in japan
as we've never heard i've never heard
that city in my life all right
world war ii oh my god i can't lose
go go go i don't know i can't lose this
the germans and the japanese they were
teamed up america being so strong and
winning that war against everybody
we did that yeah well you know america
was really
they fought the japanese really amazing
found it wow yeah we kind of killed it
literally
all right um third grade uh
i guess yeah we're back on ethan um what
type of feather
beginning with the letter q did people
write with during the middle quill
next okay harry potter
harry potter tricia julius caesar was
the emperor of
wendt empire good luck you don't know
anything i know julius caesar
um honolulu rome that's correct rome
uh at two brutes wow i know
ethan what is rosa parks most famous for
uh
she was a civil rights uh activist who
refused to sit in the back of the bus we
will uh overcome
that is correct ironic because the cool
kids sat in the back of the bus when i
went to school
isn't that funny it is funny yeah that
is a really good observation about race
what's the score anyways the score is
eight ethan 10 trisha
oh
oh thank you babe wait what you're
keeping score too
what a freak wait why you have the wrong
wait what what do you have moses no she
got wrong
so i'm at 11. did you not give her a
point for rome oh i didn't hear her
yep thanks moe's oh my god wow moses is
[ __ ]
ch fact checking your ass okay you're
literally the fact checker over there
with the lie detector dude what's going
on
all right yeah these fact these lie
detectors are both [ __ ]
go ahead dan i'm coming you're not gonna
win i was like you can't catch me that
quickly
tricia trisha three points this is the
final third great question
um for me or him for you oh all right
the first
fireworks were invented in the seventh
century in what country
you wish you knew what is with that a
firework
correct you'll never go hiroshima
i'm sorry hiroshima is not a country oh
where uh it was invented in china i knew
that china
china invented next give me a question
oh my god
so competitive yeah i got a thousand
bucks online i can't oh yeah i get loser
trisha paytas
she didn't know anything about world war
two just because i don't know what a
murder of crows is
next damn let's go i gotta be surprised
that english one [ __ ] me good
i'm surprised how ignorant i am because
you're creative and you do like
i majored in english lit but i never
learned
but like i always had like a blind spot
about all these
weird like basic elementary school [ __ ]
really that's so weird i never
learned like advert like i never know i
was like what the [ __ ] that
like grade school no i never went to
school oh they homeschooled you
anti-vaxx no i'm kidding i went to
school oh i just thought it was a weird
question
hey well people dumb school now yeah no
i went to school i just
i don't know what happened i just missed
like the whole like third grade or
something adventure has a bunch of
dummies up there
i look [ __ ] good you're right you do
look so good i'm like gel
because i look so gross next you oh
that's kind of the hot one all right
let's move on to fourth grade uh ethan
what ancient civilization built
machu picchu complex in peru
that was would be the aztec that would
be the [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] the incas was the
correctness
machu picchu uh trisha what ancient
egyptian writing system what was the
ancient egyptian writing system called
we love egypt um
who's we me and moses we watch from
egypt you guys love egypt that's like
the theme of our bedroom right
yeah you have a bedroom theme yeah it's
like prince of egypt themed
fans yeah but not the holocaust
because i don't know but they wouldn't
think that you did that like going in
the shower like but that was like so
inappropriate no no no
no oh my god that's not that's not what
i'm saying so who would be going in the
shower you were moses
moses said he made this joke himself
that he'd be the first to die in the
holocaust because he loves showers like
he showers three times a day he's like
i'd be so excited to like go anyways
that was his joke not mine don't come
from me um that'd be hieroglyphics
hieroglyphics is the correct answer we
love egypt
we love egypt why do you love egypt so
much i just found out it was real on
your show on h3
that's what i'm saying that's why i'm so
upset that i can't lose
that you didn't you thought egypt was a
mythological place fake like cleopatra i
thought was fake like i thought
everything was fake and this is a whole
new world to me
shout out how are you real i like egypt
now
like yeah okay go ahead all right
uh next up ethan from whom
did the united states buy the territory
in the louisiana franchise
next oh okay i knew that too saka julia
i was on it you are on the uh that is
not related
yeah unrelated okay go ahead um who
wrote the national anthem of the united
states of america tricia
oh i know this it's like from hamilton
right wave the betsy ross's flag higher
betsy ross
wrong that is incorrect she made the
flag oh what the [ __ ] what was the
something keys francis scott key oh
oh got it good thing it wasn't my
question that was not in hamilton by the
way
i was like oh [ __ ] is she really gonna
pull a hamilton lyric out and figure
this
i know this that would have been crazy
all right go ahead all right fifth grade
last uh last grade this section are you
getting nervous
i got kind of like i really hate losing
you know your hands and black face today
no i try to scrape it off for today's
episode that's good oh my god you can't
see that we'll get cancelled your hand
your hands are in black hand
they were black hand i don't know okay
i never lose yesterday on family game
night did we lose once no i lost one
every single time go ahead dan you're
gonna lose
all right fifth grade tell me a thousand
and ethan who
uh what was the name of the last queen
of france
the last queen of france correct um
probably that uh probably that dummy who
got her head
dink donked off uh marie antoinette
that's correct okay movies score
10 12. 10 12. let's go
that's right but i'm i what you went
first so i have go ahead
all right uh trisha the region known
as the fertile crescent is located in
present day
what a fertile crescent right
what it's such a hard question is it i
don't know how
anybody do you know the only reason i
know is because like i read some really
obscure thing
it's super obscure oh
cool i would say
oh what's that state wave in the middle
is that nebraska
uh probably i don't want you know do you
know say it
it isn't is it i mean i don't want to
say it the answer is not nebraska it is
the middle east
i'm sorry oh wait what yeah what oh good
i thought it was california
really yeah i did [ __ ] and i have a
middle eastern boyfriend i shouldn't
know that [ __ ]
sorry babe go ahead dan um buck
let's see uh ethan um
the french and indian war which began in
1754 as we all know
became the north american theater of
this worldwide war
that lasted from 1756 to 1763.
dude where's the question what is the
name of that what is the name
of that worldwide war of which the
french and indian war was
one aspect oh what was the name of the
worldwide war
yes that the french and what was the
year in
1754. oh um
french indian war was probably
part 1754 you said it started what was
that that's when it started and then the
war that it was a part of the wider war
uh that came about was from 1756
to 1763. wow
i think it was the french revolution i'm
sorry that's incorrect it was the seven
years war there was oh
and uh finally trisha yes uh the modern
day city of istanbul
was known by what name in the 13th
century
it's the old name for istanbul like
who even knows istanbul like i don't
even know that i don't even know where
it is like
tel aviv i'm sorry is constantinople
so that's simple what is that constant
nipple yeah what was it
so that is the end of uh the history
section what do what score
it's two or two i have ten twelve ten
twelve what
are we doing how many categories we're
doing all the categories
an hour long yeah go what what
categories are left
uh there is geography or
science let's do you're well it's your
choice trisha's choice
that's not fair because geography
science and history are all like those
same there's no
literally three totally you i guess
we'll go with science because those are
the four
disciplines of uh of grade school
where's like musical theater i don't
think that's a core discipline
it was in what is the lyrics to hamilton
i don't think they
i teach that in school that's so oh
that's a lyric to hamilton
i doubt they covered this in boarding
school wow anyways
okay what song is that from
when philip is singing like he's about
to get
like shot he's like um that's gonna
wow okay i'm sorry i know what you're
like pressured
oh you should have heard the [ __ ] he
said about you
i was not about to they don't cover this
in boarding school oh yeah
that's a banger right there that's a
real banger two points are you nervous
to lose
yeah like this sucks i hate losing i
don't even care i'll give you ten
thousand dollars i don't care i just
like hate losing you won't give me ten
no it's okay i was like all right go
ahead dan
all right uh so trisha picked the
category so she'll go first right
are we doing all the categories like
we're doing geography too yes
i guess so yes it favors me the longer
we
and i don't know go that's so stupid
like we should we should be able to pick
the categories there is
you did you just picked category who
wants to be a smarter than a fifth
grader there's a musical theater
category
there's literally not yeah there
literally is why would there be a
musical theater
like music anything there should be
something else creative it shouldn't
just be like one english and that's it
it should be like creative writing like
something creative writing
this is stupid science geography and
history they're all those are the main
oh let's find out dan go ahead i don't
understand your argument go over there
you know you're going to lose trisha yes
it causes the tides oh you better know
that but what causes the time
you better know that the tides are
caused by
oh platonic plates
love it see this is why i wanted to play
this show this is what i want to do
please have you heard of the moon
that is the correct answer the answer is
the moon the moon has the american
causes
the ocean you're just a [ __ ] nerd and
that's why you want to play this check
look how smart i might not be cute like
christian not everyone wants to [ __ ]
like trust me i can like know the moon
let's see let's see how well ethan does
in this category go ahead
he's so nerdy oh my god like go ahead
studies that's why
you're actually getting mad yours being
like oh look how competitive ethan is
and now you're like
look at ethan he's a [ __ ] nerd and
everyone wants to [ __ ] me call me fat i
dare you
no because call me fast fat i can't yeah
you want to call me fat don't you no go
ahead in the comments that i was better
than you which is probably true now
i'm like pushing too like i feel like so
what are we in competition to see who's
the fattest
can we get a sponsorship for a weight
loss that'd be [ __ ] great you can
lose the most
i still would lose because i have such a
problem that even if you paid me to lose
weight i can't i have like such a
problem with it i've been trying to lose
weight for like three weeks and i've
lost a single day yeah we should do
something like
uh and nicole like trim swap baby you
know like one of those commercials we
get no lipo no secret life
okay obviously you were thinking about
it go ask me a question
ethan the uh the south pole of the
magnet and the north pole of another
magnet will do
what the [ __ ] you say
the south pole of a magnet and the north
pole of another magnet will do what
stick together that's correct this is so
stupid
trisha what is this trisha what is the
force that causes
objects to fall to the ground
girl you better i know this because my
titties are low thanks to gravity
yay a personal anecdote can we just also
say we don't actually need gravity
but that's a different thing like do you
mean i saw someone do this this is a tic
tac we were watching something where
someone's like we don't actually need
gravity we're watching this to me
like we actually don't need it what do
you mean that we don't need gravity
what if it was never invented invented
by who
sir isaac newton isaac newton created
gravity
whoever created gravity if someone did
but we don't actually need it
there was a time on earth before gravity
existed yes
who who created gravity babe
dan it was isaac newton right
you were in the right ballpark sir isaac
newton perhaps uh first defined
and discovered gravity what do you mean
we don't need gravity i'm curious about
that we just don't
need it but like what do you mean the
moon doesn't have gravity
oh it does all bodies all celestial but
i mean all bodies almost gravity
anything with mass has gravity in fact
some would say you have a sizeable
amount of gravity what does that mean
i'm fat you're calling me fat yeah
attractive thank you moses
well you're fat you're a fat fat
fatty it doesn't bother me keep eating
fatty
oh my god go read a book and eat
chocolate fatty
we don't need gravity i don't understand
that statement what do you mean by it
like that we could exist without gravity
yes
you know we would just be floating
around nothing would be anchored to the
earth yeah but if that's all we know
nobody would know any different
how are you going to exist on this earth
without gravity you'd be
thrown into outer space there'd be no
atmosphere there'd be no oceans
literally i was talking about like i'm
literally checked out of this
conversation
okay let's keep going let's move on
what's the score
well let me explain gravity is like a
natural force
nobody cares about this like everyone's
gonna you want me to explain what
gravity is nobody wants you to explain
this
i don't care about them i'm trying to i
want it seems like you want to know what
gravity is i have no interest in gravity
you should know what gravity is trisha
why i just feel like it's important to
understand the world you live in that
you have to know what gravity okay well
you should know sutton foster and you
don't know her so
what you're right musical theater icon
legend starring in the music man with
chris jackman at the winter garden
theater
next march can i just explain what
gravity is to you real fast no and she's
like
so how about learn your [ __ ] and then
you can teach me i feel like gravity has
more
relevance in our daily life than tony
awards
all bodies gravity's award show like
nobody like nobody cares no one's giving
up
this conversation about graphics i can't
believe you're such a nerd that you
can't this one's about gravity nobody
cares i don't care
audience isn't the carrot nobody in this
room cares i'm over this
okay let's just let's go ahead oh my god
it's burnt we're almost there yeah
okay the hour's almost up thank god
thank god
oh my god this is i knew you were gonna
get you're getting so mad about gravity
when i didn't know the categories
otherwise like i wouldn't have even
participated in this episode you
wouldn't okay go next next sex before
she leaves the caterpillar changes and
grows into what ethan oh my god say
again oh butterfly next i win
so hard all right next question uh we're
going on to second grade here
wow what is h2o also known as oh my god
water oh my god yeah okay so wait are we
tied
no ethan 12 trisha 14. you're still in
the lead traditionally wait i gotta be
panicking
bill you're
i think i'm only behind by one because i
got one more behind by one but then when
she just got
okay go ahead go ahead right oh my god
gas is in the air that we breathe
oxygen great and what gas do plants
breathe
in that humans are you asking me no i'm
asking nutrition
what gas do plants breathe in that
humans and animals breathe out
i say that one more time what gas do
plants breathe in
that humans and animals breathe out
humans breathe in and animals breathe
out opposite
no humans and animals both breed this
gas out
plants breathe it in
carbon monoxide oh you're it's carbon
dioxide not mono oh
this is something it's co2 it's not
[ __ ] let's keep it
gravity exists and we need it uh what uh
what galaxy is the earth located in
milky way so hard you wouldn't know a
milky way
oh you have a lot of gravity so you
don't even know what gravity is
how do you know if you have a lot of it
i know by
the insinuation okay so what is this
score
go ahead ethan 13 trisha 14. go go go
all right stupid
hey uh hey oh i'm muted sorry um
this one's a throwback to a previous one
what phenomenon might be felt on the
surface when two tectonic plates
rub against each other tricia earthquake
that's right yeah also
the hardest naturally occurring mineral
is
ethan diamond that's correct what is the
closest planet to the sun
tricia
who cares about space and gravity
literally who does though who cares
we don't need gravity mars i'm sorry it
is mercury
that's some [ __ ] everybody knows
that the process by which plants eat
and make energy is called photosynthesis
that's correct
are we tied game tie game it's tied game
we're excited trisha
get excited all right fourth grade here
we go
trisha what is the part of the eye that
controls how much light enters
the cornea no your corn it's through our
cornea can you just shop
jesus it's the pupil i'm sorry it's so
annoying everyone
this is so stupid nobody even cares this
episode's gonna dude i don't care about
them
dang go nobody watch this go go go go go
go
go what planet is nicknamed the red
planet oh
mars give him the easiest yeah like
everyone knows
mercury is obviously the closest okay
all right uh what animal
uh or i'm sorry tricia animals that eat
only meat are known as
only meat carnivores
that's right yeah yeah how long does the
earth
take to revolve around the sun oh my god
365 days
one year that's correct this is so dumb
you're giving me you know it's 365.
yeah you're freaking dumb [ __ ] this is
so dumb i'm winning um
or am i in the lead
uh the earth is at least
how many billions of years old oh good
question
well let's see god made it and according
to the bible
jesus christ well if we go
if we count the old scriptures and go
back thousands i think they say about 6
000.
i found out the jewish years like 56 51
or something like that
um how many billions
yes we are the earth how many billions
of years old is the earth
two it's four i thought it was six
well you're an idiot well it says at
least how many billion years i just want
to like lose so i can flex i can pay him
a thousand because i know he would never
do it he knew an installment what
i would pay you i would do an
installment yeah i
set up that payment plan i would do like
after
can i hit you with a little interest
it's stupid
should we call it off you want to call
me the winner okay okay
all right i'm ready you just said it go
ahead dan we're almost there we're
almost there
i thought that's what you wanted i
thought we were only picking two
categories go ahead
go ahead [ __ ] oh my god this is
[ __ ] all right ethan stupid
uh what are the three states of matter
you can resign any you can end this any
time you want do you know what the three
states of matter are it's your question
gas um liquid ground solid oh i'm so wet
from that but you got laid all the time
with that knowledge so [ __ ] hot i'm
not trying to turn you on i'm trying to
take your money
sure do you understand how humiliating
would be to lose to someone who doesn't
know that egypt's real
do you want whatever
i'm trying to make look i'm trying to
make an interesting show jealous of me
it's insane
i'm trying to make an interesting show i
didn't want to sit here and talk about
like
what's wrong with trisha every episode i
wanted to make it like more interesting
yeah i like the highlights you always
say trisha betas versus gabby hannah and
you know
i don't even get a percentage of the
highlights you get all the highlights
and you use my name every single time
i mean i do that with everybody you
wanna you want so you you want me to
read
i'm not a guest i'm not a guest you when
you do with eli you're not like
you love this it's always just like
whatever the topic is you're discussing
you think about that you literally dated
me last time like who do you hate the
most like who like all this stuff
and you're like so you have an issue
with anthony bring up drama from eight
months ago for a shitty highlight
no it wasn't for the highlight i was
just curious you want you really want to
cut it that highlight
yeah i really want to kind of that
highlight so are you so
d you suggested maybe that i recoup the
cost and then split it
on the highlights channel yeah you want
to do that
or just put me in touch with people who
do daddy fresh so i can make my own
clothing line
the people who make teddy fresh ela no
like the people like manufacturing like
a team too
oh you mean our employees yeah and then
that way you can have the podcast
highlights and we'll call it even
you want my team but my team they work
full-time for teddy fresh okay well we
can find can we find another
team like put together another team like
you guys did teddy fresh but for me
oh my god dude it's not that easy it's
very difficult
i have an idea for a clothing bra fine
whatever i'll do myself what is it von
dutch wants to clap with me so maybe
i'll just do that wait what's your idea
i'm gonna wear it every episode and i'll
promote one i'm not gonna tell you
you think i'm gonna you think that we're
competing in the clothing i'd kill you
guys in the clothing i think that's what
it is like i just would like murder you
guys in that
and not a group of crows so you want my
team to make
a competing brand what the [ __ ] how
about we get a percentage like i feel
like that's fair like take a percentage
like
you know anyways we can talk about later
when we never talk we never talk outside
this show
it's like hey what's up bye can we just
you wanna do you wanna resign
it seems like you wanna resign no
because you know i could actually win
now let's go
right all right i mean i just wanna end
it so that we can we only have a couple
more questions
wait i thought we're doing no wait we
have another we have another category
yeah that's not fair
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] end it just
because i'm winning two hours
in this category relax muscles what the
hell
really yeah is that impressive oh my god
really you're pregnant you're waking
you work out or no no well low-key
impressed what are you oh it's because
you're on top
because you have more weight to hold
yourself oh really yeah right now that
i'm not
yeah that's good though that's really
good all right don't touch me that's
insane
also thank you so much for that
sweatshirt i wear it all the time the
last time oh yeah i mean i literally
wear that
all the time i'm really happy you like
it because i don't wear it so it's
amazing i never know if you hate or like
me like genuinely
i genuinely don't care about you but
like you go i
like you really convincing me that you
hate me and you're going to leave and
then you go
thank you for the jacket i love that
jacket so much yeah yeah but that's what
i'm saying i'm indifferent to you like i
don't think about you outside of this
like i think it's cool because like oh
you have like your own thing going and i
haven't been going so it's cool we did
like this collab thing
but i don't think about you outside of
this ever i'm guarded
but like not a bad way like i'm not like
oh my god i hate ethan it's just more
like
no i'm glad you don't hate me mm-hmm i
just indifferent that's good like i
leave here and like don't i have
positive feelings for you
i mean feelings for me not like romantic
like friendship
do you have something wrong with your
head because you think that any interest
a guy shows in you
like there there's such a thing as like
friendship right
not ever all in male interest means they
want to [ __ ] i don't think there's a
thing it's like guy friends like if
moses had a girlfriend i'd be like no
like a friend that's a girl no
yeah but we're not friends like that but
like i like you as a friend it doesn't
mean i want to [ __ ] i think you just
like like me as like someone to do a
podcast with
because i can do both i mean i like like
awkward afterwards like after we're done
yeah we like talk even before you're
just very like
we had a really nice conversation i
thought together out front of the house
before you left
no we didn't what about what we were
talking about when i was looking at your
yeah i was like oh i want this car is it
cool
let's just get on with it okay you're
annoying me now you're annoying me and
we're going to finish these rounds
because that's not fair to just cut him
off now that he's
let's just do rapid fire because this
shit's [ __ ] installing how many more
questions we have
just go just no more questions about
meta questions
you're the one that keeps saying it go
down don't wait just go
okay the earth has four layers it's just
far this is for trisha the earth has
four layers the thickest of which is the
mantle
what's the thinnest layer of the earth
called the foreskin
the thinnest layer of the earth correct
oh thank you i got a point sorry no wait
what you didn't answer no you were just
clarifying the question
your answer to the question was a
question
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] i thought i said something
and i was like oh i got it right
what is this what is the thinnest layer
called
the ozone that is incorrect it's
crosstalk baby let's
are known as ethan
it's not as ethan
yeah i am kind of sluggish um
without without a vertebrae is called a
invertebrate
what's your answer invertebrate okay
that's correct thank you
all right that's the end of science uh i
thought he went first
you're wrong you went first what's the
score it be
19 you pick science it's like 19 16.
and you're suffering now let's go let's
go [ __ ] jaggery
i didn't abby did it all i had nothing
to do this is so [ __ ] this is like
when you guys picked my dates for the
bachelor and i hated all the men look at
you you're in a relationship you messed
your boyfriend through
yeah what the [ __ ] how dare you
privately oh my god dare you
question my matchmaker you should be
you should be thanking me you should be
saying all praise to ethan
your life is good now because of me when
i saw the people you picked for me i
literally cried that night that anybody
would have been better than the people
you picked like nobody wants me
it literally literally cried you should
seek help no
everyone you cried yeah okay let's go
rapid fire let's go
all right rapid fire look we put the
call out those are people those are the
people that wanted to
date your stupid interns pick them
because they're also those types of
people so they picked like you expected
some a-list celebrities but like they
just weren't interested i just have a
first of all not sure because a lot of
them they didn't apply jaymore hit me up
on bumble okay
i mean fine but j j moore's not a-list
by the way but at least he's someone
better than the 18 year old ginger from
colorado
that applied i thought you wanted a
little [ __ ] i didn't think 18 you
said the minimum age 28.
oh well that yeah you're right they fell
down yes exactly
that's true go ahead dan all right here
we go
sorry how many continents are there uh
ethan
how many continents man i haven't
thought about that in a while let's see
just answer it this is so stupid
one two three
what country is paris the capital of
france
that's france in what country are the
famous
uh pyramids of giza ethan so repeat that
i was insulted i was busy insulting
what country are the famous pyramids of
giza
if they're so famous why don't i know
it's stupid
the pyramids of giza mexico
no egypt you suck oh those are the
pyramids i guess you don't know about it
oh i have
poor giza giza yeah
you know there's pyramids in mexico yeah
i got it great
i forgot i haven't thought about giza in
a while and i'm don't like have
fantasies about [ __ ] a pharaoh or
whatever you do in the bedroom
we play that we roll play ramses and
moses gross yeah wait moses
was like castaway yeah they're brothers
too
so do you like put him in the bathtub in
a basket and like pretend he's floating
down a river
like what how do you roll play that
stupid like oh do you have a cane do you
ever [ __ ] like yeah we have one at
the house
okay let's go let's go do you guys do
you guys
do [ __ ] with a cane like he's moses
parting the sea always
yeah yeah what city
gross tricia what city is the white
house located
washington d.c that's right okay cool
second grade
here we go ethan what state is called
the lone star state
texas in what state is the grand canyon
located tricia
it is in nevada
close it's in arizona that's not true
it is true uh a vegas vacation chevy
chase swings across the grand canyon and
gets
fresh it's close but it's not it's
go ahead just tap out anytime go ahead
dan how about no we could talk about
something what three countries are
located in north america
mexico united states canada
to travel from new york to london one
must fly over
what ocean tricia
atlantic that's right got me nervous
moving on to third
grade here ethan what's the longest
river in the world
um that would be the uh the nile
that is incorrect it's the amazon whoa
what continent is the country of greece
located tricia
ah [ __ ] we talk about this too [ __ ]
what's the question what continent is
the country of course
what our continent hold on oh my god i
know continents
what no i just find it interesting that
you have like these huge
we have discussions about like literally
this i'm like where's greece like i
asked
all the time um the
great greece is in the continent of
europe that's right
what is the name for a body of land
that's completely surrounded by water
ethan
so stupid island what is the capital of
new york trisha
don't you say it don't you dare say it
that's in hamilton
that's a hamilton lyric it is i swear to
god
where's that musical theater knowledge
for sure no it's not hamilton i swear to
god it's in hamilton
like many times the capital of new york
i have like a couple of gases okay well
take one what's one of them
your first one is your answer but i'll
entertain more what's the score a b
it is 23 ethan 20 trisha
oh it's closer than i thought
albany that's right i was gonna say
buffalo so thank god
i don't think by definition buffalo's a
[ __ ] game
whatever city keemstar lives in the show
where is albany in hamilton
he always says the hamel albany's the
seat of power
there's corruption in albany you're
singing that song well you're wrong
that's nice you just lost the hamilton
literally
i'll play you the song okay play it for
me when he's talking about how he's a
good
whatever let's not get sidetracked
fourth grade uh here we go
ethan what is the largest uh where is
the largest desert in the world
located that would be
the largest desert in the world
there's a couple options here there's
actually only one
is it uh
my god why are you so what i mean you're
the one who's like let's go rapid fire
you just couldn't take longer on this
question you know it or you don't
i think it's either in i mean i'll say
egypt
that's not right wow well what is it i
mean
it's northern africa okay is it part of
egypt or no yeah but i mean the desert
is much more than just egypt
so what's the answer the answer is
northern africa yeah so no way
northern africa is is that really a
specific enough
answer i probably would have even
accepted africa
of just general but egypt okay go ahead
i'm not going to argue semantics
it's the desert in egypt i mean part of
the sahara does reach into egypt yeah so
no but that's not all the whole thing
they're saying so no
oh right you would have said northern
africa no i'm not saying that but if
it's all right go ahead i don't i don't
i don't even need um
i didn't get carbon monoxide and it was
close to carbon dioxide so whatever
different conditions what is the largest
country
by size in the world
the largest country by size by
geographical area i would say russia
that would be correct wow ethan how many
kingdoms
are part of the united kingdom
so stupid these questions
uh three sorry it's four
everybody always forgets about whales
what's the score tricia is behind by one
oh
closing in oh neck and neck
uh right we have one more uh from this
category um
the united states and mexico are
separated by this river tricia
mexico separated by this river what
there's a
river separating us there's literally
nothing there
to tijuana what's um
dude you either know it or you don't
know it wait say it again say the
question one time
you know the question there's a river
between mexico and
america what or the united states what
it you know it
what do you just conjuring this no i
know it it's a song
not it wasn't that like oh my god
everything like the river jordan
wherever jordan
river jordan there's a that's not
okay well you're wrong i'm sorry that i
think actually i don't know what it is
though you don't know it's the rio
grande
the rio grande hello okay
that's a restaurant in highlands orange
colorado sorry go ahead
uh yeah so uh this makeup
is it's the last category it sits on
your face you were like
like a mask i feel like i'm starting to
sweat and really you're not gonna keep
it on
does it look like i'm sweating no not at
all you look like so mad
really yeah you look good like you
literally look like me you think i
should be a drag queen i look like a
drag queen i thought no you could be a
boy that wears makeup
you think this is attractive yeah i feel
like you're gonna like really milk into
a bunch of tick tocks and [ __ ] after
this you're gonna be like oh i look good
yeah
why are you like feeling it no well i
think it's funny
you look so much better without the
beard you look homeless with the beard
now you look like you have some money
kind of okay
so okay let's go ahead i'm gonna have
more money
this is the last category this is it um
what's the score i'm up by one you're up
by one you're up by one this is way too
close
this is for all the marbles i can't i
can i didn't expect it to be this close
i have to be honest i thought it was
gonna be a blowout
so this is kind of intense these
categories suck
okay go all right so he gets us he wins
what is the
yeah what is the primary language that
is spoken in the canadian province
of quebec french stupid that's great he
wins great we love it
wait that's all of them no no wait i
thought
why are you trying to i thought it was
the last one the last category
oh my god let's just move on there's too
much like preamble
trisha what which country is both an
island and a continent
you wish you knew that stupid asia
no i'm sorry it's australia asia's an
island
oh whatever i suck okay let's go
all right uh what is the name of the sea
bordered by europe to the north
and north africa to the south a sea
that's
say it again dan please uh what is the
name of the sea that's boring
was exhaling dramatically oh my god it's
my breathing
what is the sea that is bordered to the
north by europe
into the south by north africa
north of europe no no no it's a sea that
is bordered by
europe to the north in north africa okay
europe is north of it
yes and you and then and then africa
south of it south of it
mediterranean that is correct thank you
we're going to get cancelled so fast
this podcast is over like this is good
like the one
you think this is awful this is the
worst i literally made fun of someone
the other day specifically gabby
hannah's podcast where they were like
doing cards against humanity on a
podcast like
what the [ __ ] this is not a youtube
collab well don't you think this is
[ __ ]
not going to work harder to make it more
entertaining then okay but like
a podcast is like talking and topics and
that's exciting this is like
i'm trying something new if you have
stuff that you want to talk about you
can tell me
i mean i brought some stuff to the table
to be honest i didn't expect this to go
this long i thought i was going to blow
you out
that way it's not and blow me out
no it's not sexual okay maybe is it
sexual
no it's not i love that he's back there
oh my god why did i not know you're back
there ask me any question you want oh my
god is this it are we done is this last
question
yeah uh two more um
oh wait no this is the last question so
i lost i was bound behind
yeah that's true let's just do bonus
round all right what the humiliation
rounds
let's see there's three i have three
questions left if you can get all three
of these right tricia then you'd tie
you want to okay what kind of [ __ ]
rose is that i'm ready
the mountain range that the mountain
range that includes mount everest is
called what
you already lost it's kind of wise
the mountain range
i mean i see what the questions are in
the mountain range at what mount everest
the mountain range that includes mount
everest
all right come on you already lost let's
talk about something else at least
mountains right here
i noticed so are you going to sell me a
thousand yeah i'll do it right now
i hate i hate when people are like no
you don't have to just because we're
both rich it's like [ __ ] that no [ __ ]
when did i say that
i was like you sent me that money i'll
wear it literally right now i love
selling people because i feel so baller
i'm like oh yeah like that's just a
thousand so
what else is there anything else to talk
about um
oh there is oh yeah we already talked
about everything right
i don't know you're the one that seems
unsatisfied with the conversation
oh my god hamilton he will never be
satisfied satisfied
god i hope you're saddest do you like
hamilton are you annoyed by it
moses yeah
wait what i feel like there's it's
always like one person in a relationship
likes it and the other person hates it
oh is that you
that is my phone number yeah i mean
later says that is your
that's my company yeah okay i'm selling
you right now
give me the receipt okay such a good
idea that you propose to pay me
i love this okay i'm gonna send you a
note with it too hold on
oh okay okay yes so uh come on wait i'm
sending this to you
oh now i need an authorization code hold
on one second okay i'll wait patiently
okay hold on oh my gosh okay um
hey b who's that it's him who
the guy up here in the back okay so i
zeld you
oh [ __ ] you sent me a little extra and i
said 500
because you need it she sent me a 1500
an extra 500 because you needed maybe
you could like take a lot of dates you
can finally get laid
thank you maybe you could buy her like a
little cartier bracelet or something is
this your way of trying to insult me
because i won
no no never so do you want to talk about
anything else before we wrap it up
i agree i don't know if that was
entertaining but i'm sure the people in
the comments will tell us
literally i'm not promoting this episode
don't ever but i will be
to be like oh hey promote this i'm like
no thank you
and would you promote it if you want
yeah probably yeah but i didn't and this
is stupid because the categories are
stupid
watch billy madison at the end of the
day okay let's do something
a b just do something real fast look up
he could just do musical trivia
google is that what you want oh yeah
well i don't know anything about that
but go ahead gosh
i literally don't know anything about it
i mean but go ahead
give me yeah three thousand no i
wouldn't put a dollar on that
just give us some questions also okay so
can i make a plea for our first guest
our only guest the only guest i care
about i don't want any other guests can
um sasha baron cohen has a new movie
called borat too coming out and we
love borat i love sasha baron sasha i
saw him on a first class flight and he
gave me like a look he was like
you think he want to [ __ ] you obviously
no i really love him sasha american i
love you as borat
my boyfriend's off like boy i literally
was like oh my god he's something boring
he's in the shower and he actually does
like it's so funny
yeah but i can't you sound like bora are
you insulted by that it seems like an
insult
yeah in the tower but she's saying you
sound like an idiot
he does kind of the accent is not sexy
and i tell them all the time like why is
your section so unsexy like everyone
else is accident sexy
um joshua corn israeli though what's up
anyways can we have him on the podcast
is there anything that bothers you about
her
no he never gets annoyed again you would
never dare answer that question
if no he wouldn't there's nothing that
bothers you about her
what about the fact she doesn't know
what gravity is no she would want she
would win if she gave her the right
category
thank you babe he wins every day i do
win every game that's why it's annoying
that i didn't lose
this what does that mean she would win
if you gave her the right categories
yeah if you
if you cherry-picked every random trivia
thing i know and asked me
of course i would win that doesn't make
any sense diverse enough like the people
who know
science history and geography all know
that but if you know like creative stuff
there should have been evil even
creative categories versus like
science some [ __ ] about yeah okay i
got some
music trivia which famous music group
was formerly known as the new york i'm
sorry the new yard birds
wait first of all this is not musical
theater this is just music
it's got to be theater i mean musical
theater music yes i mean i don't know
but like
knowing about theater is not like
cultural literacy i mean
beat the geeks they always had like
musical theater movies
television like there was multiple
categories and then there was like what
do you want you want television no i
want musical theater
okay go hurry hurry maybe you have five
seconds
wow great okay we're out right now oh
wait why can't we have swash of baron
cone on this podcast
because i'm a [ __ ] nobody how about
rick moranis
i don't think he even does interviews
how about mel brooks
mel brooks he's like is he alive yeah
he's alive but he's in his 90s and it's
a pandemic anyone else
how about jesus he's not jewish let me
how about hitler he could teach you
we'll bring him back reanimate his body
do we have the same lashes trisha what
broadway tricia what broadway musical
features the song good morning baltimore
hairspray good morning baltimore every
day's like
an open door dude this is a can of worms
bro i don't know that oh we should
yeah ask ethan ask ethan the questions
yeah go ahead
ask him get one right all right while
the term broadway generally refers to
venues with a seating capacity of at
least 500 people
smaller theaters are referred to off
broadway
that's correct see i know [ __ ] that
wasn't really a musical theater
broadway musical features the song and i
am telling you i'm not going go
no no it's your turn treasure no ethan
chance because i know all these of
course i know all these so it's like
the uh what's the question what brought
my musical features the song
and i'm telling you i'm not going oh
that was um spider-man the musical
no okay reference and i am telling you
i'm not going no i'm not living without
you and you and you and you he
all gonna love me so what's the answer
trisha hello
dream girls are you are you
you're really into theater and um did
you want to be an actress or
like uh i always wanted to be an actress
but i can't act or sing or dance so i'm
kind of screwed
right so you did the next because i pay
people like beetlejuice i like paid a
bunch of like professional dancers and
stuff to like dance around me and
pretend like i'm in a musical
it works i was thinking in the kitchen
today i was doing like
things i was doing a duet to my tic toc
and i was like singing like really
belting i
think i always sound really good until i
hear myself back and literally yeah oh
my god what is with these dogs
what do you how dare you he's so sweet
oh okay sorry i love you okay anyways
i'm gonna take this off so we can pick
up alfredo sorry uh can i pick up the
brown one
come here yeah
shredder doesn't like being picked up oh
my god he runs for me why does he hate
alfredo's really sweet he'll let you
hold him alfredo will definitely let you
hold offense alfredo what he's so cute
all right is there anything else we'll
just wait here come here
come on oh he licked my face okay that's
fine so is there anything else
okay let's do musicals with dogs in them
go annie
okay i'm done this episode is over um
well we
well okay i mean look we're trying
different things
are you glamoring shot with my dogs yeah
i look really cute with this dog
actually
brad so cute hi i'm ellwoods and this is
bruiserwoods we're both gemini
vegetarians
that's my costume today it actually goes
with my costume wait you never told me
what you're dressed up as
l words from legally blonde huh
it's not up to me just let me be all
right legally
blonde check out my tick tock just like
fish 88
well thanks for watching everybody i am
the trivia
master obviously weak in the english
department but came back strong and all
the other departments that
people bicep department too you know
what i'm saying
you lied about that oh no actually like
loki you're
strong and low-key hot today like i
don't really care for you either way but
you're low-key hot today
okay whatever um ela was okay hot today
too though
oh yeah she always looks good this uh i
was gonna try it i gotta wrap it up
oh my god i just saw myself in the you
look so gorgeous we didn't talk enough
about your james charles look
what do you want to say ask me something
you never ask me anything i always come
here and i'll deal with your [ __ ]
and you're sinking and like
oh hamilton and [ __ ] that's what i
say hats and whatever
this is my first time everything i ask
all the time i'm like how much how much
sex do you guys have a week which i feel
like everyone said you were lying i said
you had it once a week you definitely
don't
you think i have less for sure like
probably wait what do you mean
everybody's lying yeah everyone's like
oh ethan's not telling who's
everybody abe what am i telling the
truth yes yeah there you go
can i have him like for a week fred is
that okay
no he's not down why not he's definitely
not done
he's looking at me like save me no he
loves me
yeah let me put you up a little more oh
fred is like save me please oh i love
all right i'm over it
get out no oh my god can we take talk
real quick
yeah sure oh are you ending the show do
we get sponsored being a sponsor this
week oh no thanks
shane wait so
come on let me out of this
okay okay oh i thought we were done okay
[Music]
bye
you